a lot of people don't associate a sport
like boxing with women I mean you get
hit in the face you mess people up but
you love it and you've been pursuing it
ferociously since you were so young why
is that well you know I just love boxing
I love training I love competing I love
showing that I'm the better fighter it's
not about who's stronger cuz people
don't know a lot of girls like boxing
hands are way stronger than me but he
just about showing who got the best
skills and who train harder and that's
why I love boxing because I train hard
and I get the results that I want it's
not like a trick question
you know you train hard you win you
don't train hard you lose that simple so
let's talk about the London 2012 games
first time they introduced women boxing
yeah you took home the gold
what was the feeling when they announced
you at the winner you know what I I kind
of knew I had won the fight against
Russia before I got in there before I
entered the ring I knew I wanted I had
watched footage of her and I just knew I
was a better fighter but just to
actually hear it and to actually be
announce the winner I was on cloud 100
for I don't know how long and I didn't
believe it at first like I went to sleep
that night and I woke up and I was like
I hope I didn't really jig silver or
something so should you check the
seasons I checked and it was go I just
started screaming a bit like yeah I
really did it for the first year and a
half how years I was just down here
beating up guys it was just something I
would like to do I like to Train tell me
about the film that
around four years well the name of the
film is t-rex
that's my boxing nickname the film crew
actually gave me a lot of motivation to
not fail you know you have not only was
they following me but they looked up to
me and they they wonder what was best
for me because that will be best for the
film there's definitely a tough element
to boxing I mean it's a fighting sport
but when you came back from London a lot
of people were telling you hey and the
interviews don't say I like beating
people up like soften your image a
little bit yeah how did you think about
that like trying to like having to
change who you are and how you represent
yourself I thought it was I thought it
was crap like I didn't want to hear that
I don't try to sugarcoat anything you
asked me a question I'll tell you how I
feel do you think that there's just a
double standard in women's sports when
it comes to gymnastics and something a
little tougher like boxing I think that
has changed I think strong is the new
skinny gabba delicate strong but I'm
stronger I told people to stop asking me
about Gabby Douglas clean skin redone I
was like don't ask me that because I'm
not her and like I said she's the 41st
person to ever do that in the first
african-american I'm the first person
period and that's my making any any any
shape hair because I'm quite sure she
can't box like me and I'm quite sure I
can do any flip like her physically I
think men in general are kind of um
intimidated by women like me and I meet
a lot of guys who are but they respect
me when when I actually talked to them
they would approach you different than
they would approach me because I'm
scared of me yeah not afraid of you but
they want the pretty sport I don't think
I you're not gonna see me boxing and
smiling you're gonna see me boxing mad
punch anybody you know like handling
business that's what you're gonna see me
doing you're not gonna see me you know
after I hit them I don't wanna go no
you're not ever going to see that you're
gonna see me smile once I get the
decision I went I know that I'm paving
the way but it's like I'm not doing it
so I could really can't dwell on it yet
you know I'm just keep going up to that
up lettering then I really make it to
the top then I'll be able to sing okay
now my job is done so that's what I'm
that's what I'm trying to do Jamie I
changed six days a week
okay this big sacrifices in boxing I
don't drink I don't smoke